Now let's compare cross-site request
forgery and cross-site scripting.
In cross-site scripting,
the user's browser
trusts a badly implemented website
that does not check input content.
That is, the attacker is able to inject
a script into the trusted website and
as a result, the user's browser
executes the attacker's script.
In cross-site request forgery a website
trusts that requests are from the user.
But in fact, the attacker forges
user requests to the website.
As a result, the website executes
the attackers malicious actions.
Both cross-site scripting and cross-site
request forgery are the results of
security weakness of websites.
In particular,
the lack of authenticating and
validating user input.